un accord provisoire dans l'attenté
d'une réelle entente durable
à deux jours de l'entrée en vigueur
d'une loi limitant les inspections sur
le nucléaire iranien
les pourparlers entre téhéran et
l'agencé internationale de l'énergie
atomique était attendu de retour à
vienne après une journée d'intenses
discussions dans la capitale iranienne
ce dimanche le directeur de l'eeie à
raphaël grossi a salué cet accord
bilatéral il y aura mon accès je le
reconnais il y aura moins d'accès mais
nous avons été capables de maintenir le
degré nécessaire de contrôle et de
vérification pour ce que nous définirons
comme un accord technique temporaire
nous nous sommes entendus sur quelque
chose qui sera viable est utile pour
combler les écarts que nous avons en ce
moment cela sauve la situation
maintenant mais bien évidemment pour une
situation stable et durable
il y aura besoin de négociations
politiques qui ne sont pas de mon
ressort
du côté de la diplomatie iranienne
cet accord n'empêchera pas l'application
de cette fameuse loi dès ce mardi et
dead man for the wolf of crime ait ce
n'est pas une date limite pour le monde
ce n'est pas un ultimatum
il s'agit d'une question intérieure
entre le parlement et le gouvernement
mais nous sommes une démocratie nous
sommes censés appliquer les lois du pays
et le parlement a adopté des lois que
cela nous plaise adopte alors que
l'accord de vienne conclure en 2015
garantissait client ne s'équipent pas de
l'arme nucléaire en échange d'une levée
des sanctions à son encontre
téhéran a décidé en 2019 de s'affranchir
d'une partie de ces obligations
en réponse au retrait unilatéral des
états unis l'année précédente